it is flintoff look at him look at him
look at him here we go really playing at
Old Trafford and defending against the
great it was of the theater of Dreams
who was out defending against here
defending against Michael Owen well as
it can see from Mike alone who had been
in the shape that he's in at the moment
on that picture I need to need a tank to
knock him over so yeah he's been in a
good paddock over the last few years is
Michael Oh what did I sign that someone
had been carrying in their pocket for 14
years this is a ticket of the 2005 ashes
it is the 12th of September the day that
changed a lot of our lives when we won
that ashes series the OCS balcony
complimentary didn't even pay the prick
where were you when we were paraded
around London on this day in 2005 who am
i posing with I'm with Freddie Flintoff
and he doesn't remember it is Flint off
look at him look at him look at him I
don't want to remember that hairstyle
and I don't want to remember that fat
face either the lads whom are posing
with in this photo
I think there's John Barnes Jamie
Redknapp Freddie
there it is I told you it'd never look
at his golfers tan that's the golfing
ten John Barnes at Eton Michael Owen
pretty clearly didn't breathe for a
minute before that photo either look at
a museum
well who walked out with me at the MCG
in this photo
Will Smith he's always been a big fan of
mine he loves his cricket what a load of
shite never met the bloke in my life
before he was touring Australia he
thought let me get a photo opportunity
during the big bash and I think I spoke
to her very good for about 30 seconds
and he will not even remember that photo
the same as Freddie and I don't remember
that photo Downing Street the Will Smith
will not know who that prick is Easter
dates now who's feeding me champagne
Piers Morgan it's amazing that that
bottle his Chin's are not on that bottle
he must have also been breathing him
like Freddie was in that picture of us
in our swimming costumes he did put a
picture of him and trump up yesterday
and I said was it a chin off honored and
privileged to get the backing of and the
encouragement from which politician
backed my campaign here Boris Johnson a
good buddy of mine Boris nearly the new
Prime Minister be nice to have a direct
line into the from a list they wouldn't
it so here it is just me basically
having the opportunity to go to customs
house and identify traffic rhino horn
which is a horrible thing to do but in
my campaign against something that's so
brutal and something that's destroying
one of the most beautiful places on
earth and some of the most precious
creatures on earth I need to get these
things done I'm Kevin Peterson and I
know my social media
[Music]